a Chad or you can also contact us so
some of our team is going to be here on
chat if you want to get contact
information please do come and as you do
and please make sure that you are muting
your microphones we will be having a
question and answer portion of this
webinar again so please use that
discussion to ask any questions at the
end and in the meantime as you join
please make sure that you your
microphone and you are obviously welcome
to used to ask any questions at this
time okay and we will start in a couple
of minutes
and for Team if you could please record
the session
okay welcome everyone to the program
we're going to start and today's session
is a part of our program called a
hands-on biomedical data science it's a
part of our series called onyx logic in
this series we talk about different
types of data and we talk about
different types of analysis as well as
challenges so this particular program
the data science program is focused on
preparing the data for analysis using
visualization using processing tools and
then using practical approaches to get
insights from that data and we'll talk a
lot about machine learning and data
normalization preparation and
visualization other things so this is a
full course that combines user-friendly
processing and machine learning methods
designed for high-throughput biomedical
data with practical skills in art in
excel on the ti-84 platform to visualize
and gain director insights and make your
research reproducible data-driven and
more impactful the program is focused on
biomedical data and we look at
biomedical data in the context of
specific types of data and specific
types of questions and so when we will
talk through this session today will be
focused on Nash generation sequencing
and onyx technology so we'll talk about
a variety of different use cases for
this type of technology and we'll talk
about different tools that you can use
to process and analyze this kind of data
and so today's session is again a free
session for anybody that is learning
about the omics logic program learning
about the specific data science program
if you're still not registered we
encourage you to ask any questions that
you have about the program the duration
of the program the types of activities
that we have and you can place your
questions in the chat box and we'll be
happy to answer those so I hope that
everybody that I wanted to join has
joined and let's talk about the program
a bit so the program is split up into
five different parts four of these
arts are introductory in in the sense
that they are designed for training and
then the fifth part is actually focused
on projects so this session is going to
be the conclusion of our introductory
session section and the introductory
section is really designed to introduce
everybody to high-throughput data
experiments challenges and opportunities
associated with high-throughput
molecular data and we'll introduce
different types of omics technologies
including genomics transcriptomics and
other type of data types for example
metagenomics and we'll talk about
different types of studies studies
related to precision medicine molecular
data analysis for mechanistic
understanding and topics like drug
discovery and discovery of drug efficacy
then the second portion of the program
we will be talking about exploratory
data analysis the need for statistical
understanding of our data properties and
characteristics and the way to prepare
data for analysis so a lot of steps are
needed to introduce first of all convert
the data from unstructured to structured
and then once that processing step is
done you also have to play around with
data to prepare it for the type of
analysis that you will be doing because
these different things have assumptions
about the data data distribution and
other property except to identify by
looking at our data from the standpoint
of visualization and statistical
analysis so we'll talk about probability
correlation association and we'll talk
about some common data visualization
techniques that are typically used for
exploratory data analysis and we'll use
two examples using Excel and using R and
we'll start talking about how you can
and you know I don't think there's
anything wrong with doing things in
Excel there's nothing wrong with doing
things and are a lot of people would
probably do it in both some things are
easier to do the next
some things are easier easier to do in
our it eventually as do specialize you
kind of pick the type of environment
that is most relevant to what you are
doing so after that we're going to talk
about data mining for data mining we'll
talk about machine learning techniques
that help us reduce the dimensionality
of our data so things like principle
component analysis and some others and
then we'll talk about what are the
features what are the objects how do we
actually find insights using some of
these data mining techniques and we will
talk about clustering methods as well
and in the context of clustering and
principle component analysis to do all
also talk about data preparation that
can help us make the most insights when
we look at the results then we'll talk
about classification and classification
is a number of machine learning methods
that are used for discriminant analysis
decision trees using varieties of
decision trees like random forests and
support vector machine so we'll really
talk about a number of different methods
there after these first five sections of
the program we believe that any one of
you is going to be ready to do their own
analysis now this is not a requirement
this is something that we think is going
to be helpful to you so we will help
prepare the project idea so that your
project idea is clear and very defined
and focused and then we will help you
apply your idea in the project design to
the actual data set of your choice I
will talk about how to find the data how
to prepare the data how to process and
analyze the data and then finally how
might you interpret that data during
that time will be available to help on a
one-on-one basis that you will be able
to connect with some of our team and
discuss but also will kind of walk you
through a process of submitting that
kind of information so what is omics
data let's talk about the history of
genomic data to understand how we got to
where we are today so as we all remember
in the 1950s the DNA
double-helix structure was discovered
and as a result of that discovery we
understood that so the net this data is
recorded in the DNA has to do with a
sequence and that sequence of DNA that
nucleotides in the DNA is really what we
call today genomic data so later on as
this discovery became more practical
what we applied it to is the assembly of
a full genome how do we put together a
full sequence and in this case we used
it on the human genome again somebody
turning on the microphone so I'm going
to okay and anyone that's joining now
just please mute yourself as you are
joining again if you have your video on
you can go ahead and turn that off and
if you have any questions please feel
free to to ask them in chat okay so
assembling of the human genome project
just to give you a perspective where we
are today with that as a result of that
project the human genome project
next-generation sequencing was started
to become more more affordable and so
Illumina picked up that idea of shotgun
sequencing and really made a very
popular nowadays application
next-generation sequencing making it
cheaper and more effective and more
precise so as a result we now have in
2015 by 2015 there was already 1,000 of
genomes of human genomes and that was
the 1000 genome project and in 2018
we're actually talking about thousands
and thousands of genomes for example
there's of 100
the genome project by genomics England
and in that the Broad Institute and
recently you might have heard that the
UK biobank is a new project that is the
most ambitious yet that will actually
assemble five hundred thousand genomes
so there is an exponential growth of
this data look what is this data really
look like so the data really comes in a
sequencing machine that looks something
like this this is the high seek 2500 and
the high C 2500 produces fast queue
format of data so the fast queue format
of data when we say it's unstructured it
looks like this so it essentially has
reads these short reads can be anywhere
between 30 and 300 base pairs long and
for each one of these letters that you
see here you have a quality score as
well and that's why it's called fast q Q
stands for quality we also collect
information that was assembled from
these short reads in files that are
FASTA format so for example the human
genome would be in the FASTA format so
this is the same type of a format where
you can see individual letters of the
code but they don't contain the quality
they actually are assembled and longer
read so here you can see reads and
sometimes you can also see whole
chromosomes assembled in a file that
looks like this
so what is you know what are some uses
for the FASTA files the FASTA files are
actually files that a lot of times are
used for full genomes over here you can
see a couple of full genomes so this is
the genome of spot-up Tara for aperto
where you can see that this is the
genome shotgun sequence so it's an
assembly of the full genome and it looks
something like this this is a virus
right here and the right the complete
genome of this rabies virus looks
something like this or just a continuous
sequence of letters what is shotgun
sequencing shotgun sequencing so as you
saw over here these are individual reads
so let's try and understand how these
reads actually are prepared so these
reads
our first the DNA the genomic DNA is
shattered as she turd into these pieces
and these pieces about 200-300 base pair
fragments you can see that then adapters
are attached to the beginning and the
end of each Reed and this is an example
of a paired end reads sequencing and
then in a flow cell that data is
amplified using PCR amplification then
the sequencer what it does is it reads
out in each flow cell it looks at the
color and the color is associated with a
letter that's why you also have the
quality control because the letters are
not always so clear that you can
understand that that is let say T G C or
a and so as a result we have this kind
of a sequence as you saw there's a label
so for example you can see here that
this is the label of the read this is an
individual position of that read and
this is the quality so the cues for is
25 how is next-generation sequencing
applied in the context of this
biological process that happens at the
subcellular level and I'm sorry I see
that we have something on the screen so
let me just see how I can maybe remove
that annotation okay so as you all know
the cell inside the cell there's the
nucleus and the nucleus contains the DNA
but that DNA is expressed in proteins
which are the functional molecules in
the cell so here in this representation
let's just break down the type of onyx
data that we have for each level of
information that we can obtain from the
cell so first of all the external
phenotype the external observation about
what the cell looks like its shape etc
is called the pheno
and we call that phenomena tria Lee
comics data in the sense that it's next
generation sequencing data but we can
also generate a lot of images a lot of
characteristics so this could be one
type of data then we have the genomic
data the genomic data is really what is
recorded in the DNA and so here you can
see an analysis of genomic data and
essentially it tells you what is in the
DNA of this specific sample and what is
in the reference genomes so what is in
the sample compared to the reference
genome and we'll talk about some of the
other things that we can do with this
kind of data then growing areas called
epigenetic analysis or epigenomics
epigenomics is really the analysis of
DNA methylation and histone modification
that we can look at from bisulfite
sequencing or chip sequences chromatin
immunoprecipitation and then we have
transcriptomics transcriptomics is the
analysis of expression of mRNA and we
can also talk about other types of rnase
micro RNAs and other types of some RNA
so there's really a number of different
things that we can study using just
next-generation sequencing so for
example in each one of these cases you
will have a different approach to
process that data in order to structure
the data for example an RNA sequencing
it's really the alignment of the reads
to the genome and quantification of
their lines reach to Dean's their
isoforms in DNA microarray for example
we can look at how we spot the changes
and individual positions and that will
be called variant calling that could be
done with Illumina next-generation
sequencing or microarray data and then
chip seek is chromatin
immunoprecipitation as we spoke and
chromatin immunoprecipitation allows us
to understand where the histones are
bound to the DNA so identify those
binding sites RNA editing we can also
explore how RNA is edited in the process
of alternative splicing and when it
becomes a mature micro RNA so in the
of data analysis on the platform that we
already started introducing last time
these are some of the sections so you
can see that we have a whole section on
next-generation sequencing data and
we'll try a couple of these sections to
understand how the data gets converted
from this raw fast u format of short
reads eventually to a structured table
that we can actually use in downstream
analysis starting from exploratory data
analysis which is going to be the next
topic that we will cover so here you can
see RNA seek transcriptomics genomics
and epigenetics you can see the whole
exome sequencing whole genome sequencing
by sulfides sequencing that we talked
about copy number of a segmentation or
copy number variation where we can look
at number of genes that are recorded
multiple times in the genome and also
metagenomics so how can we analyze data
from microbial communities the
microbiome so all of these are important
things to understand but they all share
common principles and so what we want to
look at today are some of those
principles that are applied in two types
of data transcriptomics and genomics so
one deals with
next-generation sequencing of gene
expression and other one deals with
next-generation sequencing of genomic
sequence the genomic variants so let's
first talk about next generation
sequencing transcriptomics we have the
DNA and the DNA only about 1% of that
DNA is dedicated to coding genes in
other words sections of the DNA that
record a sequence of a gene and those
genes are not going to be expressed
exactly the same way that they are an
RNA that they are transcripts so
transcript will be a little bit
different from the actual gene so the
gene gets expressed some genes don't get
expressed some get expressed more
some get expressed less and this mRNA is
what we have in our sample and the
sample the sample is shattered so you
can see that it's broken down into these
short reads adapters are attached to the
beginning of the ends of each one of
those reads then those reads are
amplified using PCR amplification and
then finally they are read so the
understanding of how the data is
prepared is critical for our ability to
appropriately process it and prepare it
for analysis so what we want to look at
now is we want to take a look at how we
can take this understanding and convert
it into a data analysis pipeline now
another aspect of gene expression is
that as we said Gene's the way they are
recorded in the DNA and the way that
they are actually expressed are not
exactly the same way so there's a
process of alternative splicing we won't
go into detail but let's talk about it
from that analysis standpoint so one of
the critical steps is alignment
alignment of these short reads as you
can see right here these are the
different reads that we have in our data
and this is the reference so the
reference has some kind of a sequence of
letters some gaps and we have a number
of reads and the reads as you can see
that it won't all start from the same
location so the process of alignment is
actually looking at how do those reads
align to the reference genome and then
using this alignment - and what kind of
exons do we have that combine and an
actual that are combined into an actual
Aiza form so let's talk about how this
works in real life we started doing this
last time let's do this a little bit
again by going to the platform so thank
you protein for putting in that link the
the platform that I am referring to is
the server that T - bio info so all of
you that have registered before the
program should have already received
your account information if you have not
received your account information you
just registered please as us about this
we will be sending you those details
today as soon as the session is over so
the again the server will look something
like this when you are there and if you
want to see that you're logged in you
will see your details right here in this
corner and what we want to do today is
just briefly go through some of the
example pipelines for rna-seq and for
whole exome seek
data to do this we actually have a full
course that you can take on
transcriptomics and on genomics that you
can learn about how this works but in
the meantime you can just learn by
looking some of these examples that we
kind of add them upon so try to explain
as much as possible how these work as we
do these pipelines so right here under
transcriptomics we have this RNA seek
chip fairly thorough analysis of
next-generation sequencing and
microarray data and we are going to take
this first demo pipeline the demo
pipeline uses the cell line data that we
started discussing last time the context
of the data is that we are using data
from a publication publicly available
data these are patient derived cell
lines and we are going to analyze that
data for gene expression that can help
us identify subtypes of cancer so let's
take a look at how do we prepare several
samples into a table of expression by
pressing on start you can read a little
bit about some of the critical steps
that are involved in this process so as
you can see we are going to start by
first pre-processing so pre-processing
will help us remove those adapters that
were attached and removed the PCR
duplicates then we are going to map the
data that we have to a reference genome
and then we are going to quantify the
levels of expression so the pipeline
will look something like this you can
see that this whole section is
with pre-processing this section deals
with mapping on transcripts and this
deals with quantification of expression
levels so this is just one example of a
pipeline that we can build now you can
see that the buttons have become darker
that I can select and what I'll do is
they'll first use the pre-processing
section to use trim ematic that will
find the actual read sequences and
remove the adapters and any technical
sequences that might be contaminating
some of the data that we have then we
will look for this step of amplification
so PCR amplification does not always
amplify every section that in a similar
way so what we want to do is we want to
remove this technical amplification so
that we are left with data that is
directly related to the biological
problem the conditions that we are
trying to study now then we have two
different options you can see that
there's an option for high set which is
going to be a combined strategy on
mapping on the genome detection of exons
and then mapping on junctions so there's
really a combined strategy or we can
directly map on transcripts what's the
difference well the difference is as I
mentioned the genes that are known the
transcripts that are known and are
recorded in an annotation file called
GTF file they are not really
representative of all the biological
variability that exists in real life and
so if we want something very detailed to
understand the alternative splicing
events we have first sample and really
understand the eyes of forms that are
expressed in each sample we wouldn't
want to use this combined strategy if we
want to just understand known isoforms
or known genes how are they expressed we
will use this annotation file and
computationally this is a more effective
way of doing it but you lose some
resolution so let's first try this one
now here you can see that we're going to
be aligning these
to the reference genome and we will use
an algorithm called bowtie 2 and bowtie
2 is a fast alignment algorithm that is
based on the seed or Kaymer approach so
this approach is actually somewhat
similar to what is used in the burro
wheelers algorithm that's similar to
what is used and when you search for
something in Google for example it's
just an effective algorithm to align a
sequence to another sequence so once we
align our sequences those short reads to
the genome and we understand or to the
transcriptome sorry and we understand
that they have covered they have certain
coverage and then they have a certain
amplification in a region one of the
other challenges is to then quantify
taking into account the number of reads
that we have in total and really prepare
given a real number so here you can see
what that table will eventually look
like and you can see that we will have
the gene ID the gene name across
multiple samples all the samples that we
upload it and for each sample we will
have a number and that number represents
the level of expression so let's click
on OK now we have prepared our data
pre-processing we then map the data on
transcripts quantified it using
expectation-maximization technique which
is also a machine learning method
actually and then we will complete by
pressing on it now if you are interested
in learning more about some of these
transcriptomic data analysis we
encourage you to go to this link
transcriptomics we have a whole section
here on transcriptomics so you are
welcome to take those courses those
courses are free and they walk you
through all of the steps that I just
described right now but also take it
further to talk about differential gene
expression and talk about some of the
machine learning that we can apply to
this kind of data as well as all the
wages single-cell RNA seek which is a
separate section on the platform now
once this
line completes again what is the concept
of the pipeline the pipeline is taking
the data loading into each one of these
algorithms completing the algorithm it's
a sequential process where we take the
data that goes into the input that
process that script or algorithm and
produces a result and then we pass it on
to the next job so that's really what
the pipeline is and here when you can
see is a logical representation of this
pipeline let's take a look at the result
so we have here a data set called cell
lines expression data so we can download
this data just by clicking right here
and once the data is downloaded we can
take a look at what's inside so we can
open this data for example a quickest
way to open it and let's just open it in
Excel so in Excel we'll be able to see
what the structured version of this data
looks like we saw what the fast q files
look like and obviously this is
something that very difficult to deal
with and here we can see how we can
convert those fast q files into a
structured format this is called the
structured format because it essentially
organizes the data by some feature this
right here is the ID of a gene and this
right here is the ID of the sample of
the cell so in here we have these
numbers and these numbers represent the
level of expression of this particular
gene in this particular sample okay so
this was one of the one of the examples
for a an rna-seq pipeline let's just
quickly try and create the other more
complex version of this pipeline so
again you can see here that we can start
with preparing the data by pre
processing the data then we can use high
Sat 2 which is an algorithm that will
for these variety of ways that the exons
could be mapped on the actual genome and
it prepares Aiza forms and so we need to
now construct these ions by looking at
the variability because
some samples will have exons present
other will not have and so we need to
have a full list of all of those
possible either forms and then we will
use that understanding of the isoforms
to actually generate a new GTF file so
the new GTF file will tell us what we
are actually mapping onto right because
at the end we will map the reads that we
have onto these transcripts and once we
map those onto the transcripts again we
need to quantify the data that we have
and once we quantify the data that we
have one obvious step that we can do is
compare conditions and this is something
that will talk a lot more about in
future lectures where we will use Dec
Dec will look at differential gene
expression so for example this is
condition number one this is condition
number two where are those statistically
significant genes that are
differentially expressed between two
conditions so we'll talk a lot more
about some of these concepts in our
lectures but also I encourage all of you
that this is covered in transcriptomics
too you can learn about the p-values and
the false discovery rate and and all
kinds of other concepts that are
relevant to this topic
now you can see that now we have a bunch
more different outputs here and the
reason is because we are just going
through this kind of step by step to
understand the complexity right so what
are some of the files that we have we
have the mapping statistics so how many
of the reads are mapped to the genome
how many were not we have the expression
of isoforms we have the expression of
genes and you will notice here fpkm and
other kind of abbreviations and we'll
talk a lot more about what these
abbreviations mean and how do we
actually use a variety of normalization
techniques to prepare data for analysis
so that is a little bit on the
transcriptomic data analysis and the
transcriptomic data analysis is really
something that we see as a preliminary
step before we can start analyzing and
understanding our data so at this point
I'm going to just take a moment here and
ask anyone if anyone of you has any
questions about this process please feel
free to put those questions into the
chat and what we happen to answer those
now we saw how pre-processing of data
mapping of that data on the reference
genome and then some kind of analysis in
that case it was quantification is used
to analyze RNA sequencing data now let's
talk about genomics data genomic data is
different and we can use a variety of
methods to analyze that data and so
we'll look briefly and how we can look
at individual single nucleotide
polymorphisms or snips or snv's so we
can look at single nucleotide variation
or we can look at copy number variation
copy number variation is variation of
the number of times that a gene is
recorded in the DNA how do we use this
data so how do we use this we one of the
ways that it could be done is by looking
at genome-wide Association so for
example how do we now associate this
variation with the phenotype that we
have about the sample just briefly going
through some of the sections that we
have here we have pre-processing mapping
an alignment that you're already
familiar with and then some new sections
including variant column differential
rain : for example for detection of
somatic mutations annotation of the data
which physicians are aware and why is
that important for example using the
1,000 genomes project using the database
of clinically relevant snips etc and
then we have some post-processing
sections here as well here are a couple
of different pipelines that could be
created to look at the data from
different standpoints let's try and
create those together so that we
understand what type of information we
can get out of them so I can see here
that somebody has raised their hands
maybe at this point it would be best if
you could just type your question into
the chat and would be happy to address
that or we can wait until we have the
Q&A session at the end so right here you
can see mutation variant parallel
analysis for mutation data by the way if
you are interested to understand how all
of these sections work you can just
quickly hover over and that will tell
you a little bit of a background of what
we're looking at so parallel analysis of
mutation variant if you click here again
we are going to use the same project the
same cell lines that these are breast
cancer cell lines we're trying to
understand subtypes of different breast
cancers and one of the ways to look at
the subtypes is to try and look at the
genomic variation so let's quickly
create one of our first pipelines now
it's important to understand that the
individual physicians that are changing
in the DNA actually have an impact on
the way that the protein ultimately will
be produced but the protein is produced
from mRNA so the process of going from
DNA to mRNA to protein is clarified by
this ability to look at first of all how
the Tri codons or sorry the
trinucleotide codons are recorded and
then how those codons produce amino
acids so quickly a question here how to
upload default fast queue files so this
is a demo version and then when we talk
about actual processing
the data you will use the non demo
accounts and there are few steps to
configure before you actually upload but
then we will use we are happy you know
maybe to get on a call to explain how to
use that so but to run the default
pipeline there's no need to upload
anything this is just a demo ok so one
of the things that we can do is we can
align the data to the reference genome
and then we can visualize that right so
to visualize the data what we can do is
use j browse a method that will show us
the actual the actual reads aligned to
the reference genome so once we click on
end you can also see here that we have a
collection of lectures on genomics
including introduction to economics and
genomics 1 and right now we are working
on genomics 2 that will be available
soon so let's take a look at the results
of visualization so this is the
visualization of a couple of samples so
you can see here that I have two samples
srr 9 and 2 5 7 6 5 and srr 9 2 5 7 6 6
so this is just two files and this is
the alignment of those reads to the
reference genome so you can see that I
have a sequence of the genome and then I
have accumulation of reads so this is
called the abundance and then here I can
actually see the nucleotides and I can
see individual positions where I have a
change right and you can see that this
change is identified by this little mark
on this level now if i zoom out I'm just
going to quickly zoom out here you can
see that actually only portions of the
genome have some coverage so the
coverage of the genome is positioned
right here I can see the annotation that
GTF file that we started talking about
and the GTF file records the positions
of exons and genes on the genomes
now I have this annotated annotation or
the annotation with the positions of
these exons and genes you can see that
this is a gene called p53 and p53 of
course is a gene that is important for
somatic mutations occurring in apoptosis
and an important gene in cancer so you
can see a number of things from just
visualizing this data first of all we
know that this is whole exome sequencing
right because the reads are only
positioned in the regions annotated by
gene so this is only gene so that's what
whole zone sequencing means the second
thing is that we can quickly browse
through and look at a variety of
positions and even search here for
various genes that we know for example
the breast cancer gene the brachot gene
can be found right here we can take a
look at this gene and we'll tell you
that it's in chromosome 17 if you go
back to p53 you will see that it will
take you to that position of the p53
gene which is actually on chromosome 1
so you can see how this is a huge amount
of data very difficult to scroll through
and just look at things from that
perspective but very informative if you
are know if you know what you are
looking for so let's try another type of
an analysis another type of fluid
analysis is when we want to identify
somatic mutations and somatic mutations
means that one we have one type of say
one sample from let's say the tumor and
another sample from let's say the blood
sample the normal sample of the same
person and we can separate the germline
mutations from the somatic mutation so
how is that done we can again
pre-process our data align the data to
the reference genome and then do what's
called somatic mutation calling so for
example using a stroke a stroke is a
method
for somatic SMB single nucleotide
variation and small endo detection from
sequencing data of matched tumor normal
symbols so you can see the
representation of what this algorithm
does and what it ultimately produce and
produces a variant call file called VCF
file we can also use another method
method called somatic sniper and it's
important to understand that for a lot
of these steps you can use multiple
alternatives and maybe these
alternatives will produce different
types of results but in this case you
get a zip file that will include both a
text file that is a table of each
individual positions and a variant call
file in the variant call file the VCF
file can actually be further explored by
looking at just somatic mutation so
again just a quick review here we looked
at coverage we looked at different
positions on the GTF file in the genome
and we looked at how do we understand
what type of information we're looking
at and where are those important
positions for us to look at we also saw
how it's not a straightforward process
for us to just browse through all of
them information that we have that is
really where the need for data analysis
comes in and one of the things that we
talked about is the p53 gene the gene
and chromosomes have that chromosome 11
I think is supposed to be where or
chromosome 17 yes sorry that we can now
interpret right being an important gene
in the tumor or in the cancer when we
are trying to analyze for cancer
mutations so this is an example of how
we can visualize the VCF file and here
you can see the p53 gene this is the
human genome so you can see it's in the
human genome has to be used as the
reference and then we have the
chromosome 17 the positions of this gene
and those individuals - Matic mutations
in this gene now how does this all to
this problem of precision treatment of
breast cancer
- talk about this and to take any
questions that you might have I am going
to pass on the host - protein and
protein Chakraborty is has a PhD in
bioinformatics and has been a trainer
with Pine biotech with with us for a
number of months and he'll be able to
walk you through some of the project
design ideas and answer any of your
questions about this about what I've
shown so far so I'm going to transfer
this over to protein pratima playing
here yeah can you hear me out of you
guys yes we can hear you okay should I
share my screen or should you continue
sharing I am going to I stop sharing my
screen and I think you now should be far
too perfect so I think all of you are
able to see my screen now
so yes any questions you have which I
would like to answer whatever earlier
covered is thank you for that it was a
pretty good you know a sufficient
understanding from the previous lecture
that what we are going to cover on and
these are some of the applications that
you can find in front of you like
modeling precision treatment of breast
cancer because breast cancer have
several subtypes like Lauren low or
normal or basal or you know there are
some other classes as well and maybe
these things these these this map out
here right now make sense little bit up
to you about the coverage of the
mutations that are being shown out here
and also the phenomics think the
molecular profiling of the breast cancer
and out of the coverage because the
coverage is very important when it comes
to next-generation sequencing because a
good coverage definitely gives you all
those details about those data so this
is one of the article very significant
article which is there and right in
front of you so where we try to
understand the cancer profiles by using
the machine learning principles which we
are going to cover in this course entire
length of this course for the next three
months and you know and then I would
like to go to you know this other some
of the projects which so reproducibility
is the need of the hour so what you need
before jumping into some project or
trying to do some solving some problems
you need to have the biological
questions pretty well defined in your
mind and would definitely like to help
you guys to you know doing this project
which is a very important part of this
course so two months of intensive
learning which will be guided by experts
like Ilya Darko and Mohit and thereafter
you have to embark yourself in doing the
project whatever you have learned to
analyze the data so these are some of
the archives from where you can get your
data from one of them is sequence read
archive which is a part of NCBI in
Serbia is a data warehouse where these
are the data
it's been submitted by various from
various experiments and on the left you
can find you know transcriptome analysis
of spa doctor of fruity pada these is
one of the projects which are available
in our educational platform those of you
are part of this course you'll be able
to access it those of you are not yet a
part of this course you will also be
able to access it but again you know you
need the server credentials which is a
part of this course anybody wants to
join I think I have already pasted the
link in the chat you can get back to us
via our email or you can get back to us
you know directly pay into the course
and then join it and carry on with the
follow for the next three months okay
anyone any questions you have I would
take up take off one to take a pause
here and I'm hearing many of you who are
already a part of this course you can
unmute yourself on a scree so we have a
patient in the chair let's see server
login pipe and I'm covering circles too
or what do you exactly mean by Sarcos if
you may tell us Anika so I think Sunita
it would be best it would be best
where so if you have logon on to the
server can you really tell us what is
sarcos
kyoko I think that kind of answers your
question okay if I if I may move on so
so the omics logic training program
which is going to cover for the next
three months is going to be very
intensive in trying to understand the
data processing and analysis and
visualizations in any sort of academic
or research or industrial exercise or
industrial projects what you need to do
the most of the data that alia already
told you about is unstructured you know
when it comes to if you really look at
the NGS data they are kind of being
produced by different type of machines
and all those machines produce different
type of you know formats so what the
major problem in the Big Data domain
right now is to structure the data it
when it comes to any other domain that
biomedical domain if you go to the you
know electronics data or electrical data
or any sort of data out there the
important part is structuring the data
from the unstructured form even in
biomedical data domain big data domain
besides NGS there are electronic health
records or electronic medical records
there are several points that there are
images there are pixels
you know the electronic medical records
contain the name of the person the
gender of the person the age and the
height and the BMI and all those typical
important things that you have to kind
of fill up a form in your pathological
labs or in the clinic so connecting all
those EMR data sets which are basically
clinical data sets these are piling up
in a huge way and thereby producing the
level of the actual deluge of the big
data so this is highly unstructured so
whatever processes that has been shown
to you by Elia on the pre-processing
part thereby we try to structure it
properly because if you don't structure
it properly
it would the statistical principles that
are being
that we are intending to use at the part
of the machine learning at the same time
it won't be applicable because genomics
data coming directly from the platform
from any sort of NGS experiment does not
follow normal distribution standard
normal distribution is an essential
starting point for analyzing data end up
with the statistical tools so before you
actually try to find all those patterns
the mutational variant or the
differential gene expression or the
differential variants all those somatic
mutations and your online mutation it is
essential that you need to structure the
data first that's an advantage and
that's also is a big disadvantage as
well so but I know you know there are
processes to circumvent that these
advantages out here to structure it
properly because if you have all those
raw short reads which are kind of have
to be mapped onto the genome have we
have to kind of get the whole sequence
out of it then then only we'll be able
to find out those significant genes and
also those important biomarkers which
can be used in precision medicine or in
any other domains that are being used
right now different concepts are coming
up you know because epi transcriptome
epigenome is also is something which
already earlier covered though histone
modification the methylation of it so
single-cell transcriptomics is it also
you know he producing huge amount of
data but again this is unstructured and
we teach you out here in this course to
do the structuring of the data the
processing of the data and definitely
Big Data has a very important factor
which is visualization because until and
unless you visualize something in front
of you in a you know in a in a big good
way would definitely be able to
understand that
where does your data fall what class are
you deserve a topology so you have a
hypothesis you have a by the biological
hypothesis to prove and these hypothesis
whether it really makes sense or not if
you visualize the data that would be the
best thing to do at your end and you
know that the methods that we teach you
we would try to you know guide you
through during the entire length of this
course has clinical perspective have
research perspective and obviously
pharmaceutical projects
you know there are significant
pharmaceutical projects or significant
pharmaceutical problems which are
occurring at the end of the day which
are coming up you know they are being
addressed there has to be addressed from
the big data perspective so we teach you
the methods and we help you to apply
those methods in those three
perspectives I think most of the
participants out here belong to that
domain and if you don't are not
belonging to the domain if you are a you
know trying to understand the data
science principles of course the
principles that we teach out here is
applicable for any sort of data so be it
biomedical data or any other data only
the structuring principles will be
different you know that data types will
be different so the basic principles
remaining the same whether it's
biomedical data or the question will
differ so that has to be you know would
be a good exercise for you to go through
this course and have a hang of things
so in throughout the entire length of
our course we give a lot of pointers
we'll give you a lot of pointers to
learn about it we do not really you know
it's its hourly lecture we do not it is
not intended to you know just mock the
things up so that's why we have built
that educational platform which actually
supplements the server platform so
anyone any other those of you have
registered for the pols I've already had
the access to the server so run at all
of them of pipelines try to understand
the input files that's why the demo
pipelines are therefore so and that
would really help you to figure out a
way to you know how you know you can
really match or cope with the type of
the things that we're going to cover in
the entire three months of course and
you know we can design and prepare and
clarin analysis and make it impactful
because that is the whole idea of it
this is a hands-on learning course it's
not about theories only so you have to
know the essential theories which will
be covered in detail and you will also
be guided through the projects you know
the project we can come as a novel
project from your part or you can do
some of the projects that we have in the
in our in our educational platform you
can go to them try to understand the
reproducibility of the research that's
the IMP
part of it so once a research can be
reproduced the methods if you have a
very ear idea about the methods that you
are you know you're going to follow that
would really translate in the process of
your own research though so that's
that's the whole idea of this omics
logic training program and as a result
of this omics logic training program you
will have a very detailed portfolio yes
anybody had any question Rana could you
do to yourself please Rana can you mute
your cell please thank you very much so
you know as a part of this omics logic
training program the whole idea are is
to help you to build your portfolio I
have heard I come across many many
participants here in this course who are
interested to learn data science as a
whole and definitely you know until
analyst you actually dig your hand into
the soil you won't be able to understand
how deep is the soil or how dirty is the
soil so that's what it is all about in
our program that you can build your
portfolio I can say up front that ok I
know this and I know that gardens and I
know the basic procedures of machine
learning principles and because you have
you know that's the whole idea of it to
build to do the project and you know the
biomedical research so also for people
who are for doing academic research and
as well as for those people who are
doing industrial research this type of
courses would definitely help you
because we have worked in industries for
a long time we have seen that you know
in real life examples that are being
thrown at you from your clients it's all
about it the research you know you have
to understand the data you have to
structure the data try to understand the
biological question your client is
trying to solve and help those clients
to solve those questions so courses like
this would definitely help you to
critically understand the scientific
concepts behind it in the biomedical
domain and of course as a part of your
course we would
also be helping you out to understand to
read research publications because
that's the only way you can really
advance your knowledge to a different
level so because most of the elementary
research which goes on in the Academy
a-- are have some translational
applications in that industry as well so
biomedical research is will be clarified
to you and the research publications
would be shared with you and also if you
come across any research publications
which is of your own interest for your
own work we can help you to Dessie for
that to demystify that as a part of your
doing your projects and definitely the
certification is very important in any
sort of course so the course entire
length of the course is for three months
at the end of that you would get a
certificate which is intern
internationally accredited it comes from
Pine biotech it comes from drawbar
bioinformatic Research Center from where
we are a technological spin-off and you
know at the same time as a part of this
course the the educational platform have
a number of modules hovering around the
genomics transcriptomics metagenomics
epigenomics etc so all these modules
also have significant individual
certificates when you complete the
courses so you can you know you have to
know the data sources because if you do
not know a data source you cannot really
call yourself you know a proper data
scientist you know what what what is
need to be done as a data scientist you
need to understand where the data is
coming from and how the data is
structured and how what what sort of you
know things that parameters need to be
said to make your unstructured data into
a structured way so that's what we are
trying to teach here as a part of the
biomedical data science course so you
can understand the basic principles of
the data and also the basic methods
which are used to structure the data so
and you know and the project at the end
of the course would help you
to make your learning into a
translational into into a translational
objective so so this discourse have a
pre-assessment and a post-assessment
and a midterm assessment would really
like to understand that what you have
really learned where we're you and at
the end of the course we're where are
you so that's very important we call our
courses extended MOOC extended massive
online course because we have a very
strong feedback system as you can
understand we have you know significant
team sitting here to help you out with
your queries and your understanding so
we are available by a check we are
available via many of the social media
platforms the number of questions I can
see this has been a dark oh thank you
very much and yeah thank you Darko so
yeah Sunita you have a question to ask
okay so this much from my side I would
really like to take up any questions if
you have if you want to join the program
I have already posted the link out there
in the in the link in the chat if you
are if you are not aware of the link I
would like to post the link once again
to you and I would be really happy to
take a question so we'll be covering
again we will be covering the data
sources and we'll be covering all those
analytical pipelines which are used to
analyze those data and come up to a
plausible interpretation in terms of
genomics in terms of transcriptomics in
terms of metagenomics as well and
epigenomics as well and we will also be
covering you know a lot of things which
comes as inherently to biomedical data
analysis which is you know data
visualization and we use our studio we
have an expert with us dark or dark oh
is the dark or le unknown it would be
helping you out to really understand all
those code modifications and the level
of at the level of the programming level
so you can you can you know run the
pipeline you can we have a our scripts
are downloadable and you can use all
those downstream analysis in the art
studio and really come up with an
interpretable so that but from my side i
would be happy to answer your question
if you have anything you can paste in
the chat or you can unmute yourself and
ask me see many questions in the chat
and be okay yeah so yeah thank you very
much
yeah so I think apart thank you apart
for posting the link if you want to join
the program that's the link you can see
on my screen a duty - bye or on info /
organizations slash omics logic - data
science slash so this is the place where
you can go you can find the curriculum
where you go to cover and also you would
be you know we can help you out to
register if you are not being able to
pay and registered you can send email to
us at you know at this place Roth in at
the rate of fine dot bio or marketing at
the rate find odd bio and yeah thank you
apart and yes Mohit protein and
marketing we have pizza with us pizza is
our community manager she will help you
out to solve your problem and help you
to join into the course though this is
the second session the next session is
on you know this is the entire length of
the course and I think I'm over I would
be happy to answer you or if you don't
have any questions I think we are
already you know at the end of our
session we would either India or
transfer the stage to Elia any of your
around
okay I think you know we are good to go
and I think we have answered most of
your questions and I think we have given
you sufficient understanding about why
this course is important to you and if
you are really wanting to jump on to the
biomedical domain as well as fortified
with the data science principles so data
science is a very important thing as you
know because all of you are kind of well
aware of it that's why you are here so I
don't want to reiterate the fact the
point is that you know this is a perfect
place for you to begin and get an
international accreditation and
thereafter go on with your in your
career as with these skills that we give
you as a part of this course thank you
very much